all sides whether it be the Taliban the
Afghan government the US forces all
sides have blood on their hands
[Music]
hi I'm Tracey Oppenheimer Friesen TV and
today we're here with Anand Gopal he is
a fellow for the New America Foundation
and author of the new book no good men
among the living and on thanks for
coming in today thanks Rob Lee so no
good men among the living it details
your experience in Afghanistan for six
years you follow three Afghani locals
and even embed yourself with the Taliban
what do you want the biggest takeaway to
be given the the current news of the the
prisoner swap with the Bergdahl and the
five Taliban but at least one Guantanamo
I think it's really important for us to
come to terms of the fact that the terms
we use like terrorists really don't even
make sense if you look at it from the
Afghan point of view that it's a lot
more complex it's a lot more fluid
there's local politics that you have to
take into account the people that we've
allied with sometimes are just as bad as
the people that the u.s. is fighting
what did you make of the Bergdahl
situation well the five Taliban
prisoners who are exchanged if you look
at their history it's very interesting
because all five were captured when
they're trying to cut deals with pro US
forces in fact one of them worked at the
CIA three of them were with the Afghan
government or we're trying to join the
Afghan government so when you think
about it in this way then actually it
there's a whole wrench into this sort of
straightforward narrative that these are
the worst of the worst terrorists that
we should never release a lot of that
stems from the conflation of the Taliban
with al Qaeda and Osama bin Laden and
you talk about that a lot can you speak
to how this created problems in terms of
US intervention the idea at the time in
2001-2002 is with it was that you're
either with us or against us so
essentially the whole world is divided
into two camps and then included
Afghanistan so basically if you weren't
our ally that means you are a terrorist
but in fact the situation on the ground
is a lot more complicated there's a lot
more gray area the al Qaeda had fled the
country in 2002 and the Taliban from the
rank and file all the way to the senior
leadership pretty much had stopped
fighting so we were left for the
situation where there's no enemy to
fight but we had thousands of soldiers
there ready
what ended up happening those we allied
with warlords who had their own agendas
so for example if you had a piece of
land and I was a warlord and I wanted
that land I could tell the US military
that you're a member of the Taliban and
since I was the only intelligence they
had they would arrest you
interesting so so that led to a lot of
corruption I think we're still only
beginning to recognize what we are role
of our complicity in this process in the
early years is one of the things I hope
to do with my book unfortunately a lot
of this history has been lost because
this is stuff that's happened deep in
the countryside where reporters usually
don't go where Afghans only should have
a chance to speak to the international
media they don't write books or write
these people articles to describe their
experiences so with the Karzai regime
you you say you don't think that they
would last a day without the American
support that they currently have can you
talk a bit about this because they're
getting so much money I mean where is it
going
well actually yes seventy percent of the
Afghan budget comes from foreign aid
they're not able to do some basic things
like even raise taxes or anything else
so they're entirely reliant on
international aid to survive and if we
stopped paying for the government
tomorrow it would collapse the army
would collapse the police would collapse
and most of the money that's going into
Afghanistan actually bypasses the
government if you look at the education
numbers the number that's usually
bandied about is that millions I don't
know exact number of millions of girls
are now going to school where there's
they didn't go to school before and it's
certainly true that more girls are going
to school now then in the 1990s that's
not disputable however the actual
numbers are it's unclear where they come
from because I went through the
countryside and would go to schools that
are officially open according to the
Ministry of Education would you get
there and there's nobody there there's
no girls there there's a teacher there a
lot of corrupt officials or pocketing
the money that's supposed to go to the
schools and then just writing it down on
the rolls these schools exist the same
for clinics the number of clinics is
greatly exaggerated so we actually don't
even know the level of service that
exists in the countryside the prospects
for Afghanistan no matter what happens
aren't great so so what's the best-case
scenario
this point I think the best-case
scenario is actually the continued the
continuing of the status quo the status
quo is that there are pro-government
forces and pro-us forces that are
concentrated in the cities and some
northern areas and there are Taliban in
the deep south in the villages that's
not a good scenario but it's better than
the alternative which is a Taliban
marching to the cities and we have a
return to the 1990s or that we have a
civil war I don't think there's any
question about the Taliban being a
brutal and oppressive regime but you
think it's important to give them a
voice why do you think it's so important
to understand them and not just say
they're terrorists the Taliban regime is
notorious for being one of the most
repressive regimes and probably the
history of the world and Afghans mostly
hated the Taliban in the 1990s these
were guys who used to walk around with
whips and what people who didn't have
beards that are long enough that kept
women in the houses I think it's
actually a terrible thing for
Afghanistan for the world that the
Taliban still exist and there was no
reason they needed to still exist
because this is a very unpopular regime
in the 1990s and we had a chance to
basically eliminate them because they
were coming to the u.s. giving up their
weapons and trying to find a way to have
a reconciliation process because that
reconciliation was spurned the US and
Afghans are still living with those
consequences today and I think it's
important to tell that story and to tell
her through the lives of those who
actually experienced it so that's why
one of the people that I follow is a
Taliban fighter but I also follow a
housewife and a pro-american warlord as
well no that was that was very
interesting thanks for coming in sure
thanks Friesen TV I'm Tracey Oppenheimer
[Music]